quienes no logran salir por vía aérea lo
intentan en las fronteras terrestres el
objetivo es el mismo huir de afganistán
tras la toma del poder por parte del
grupo talibán diariamente cientos de
afganos cruzan la zona limítrofe con el
vecino irán
tenemos entre 700.000 viajeros que
entran cada día por escuchada y en
cuanto a las precauciones que se toman
en la frontera con respecto al
coronavirus tomamos muestras hoy no va a
seguir y pactarse probamos las
temperaturas y hacemos simetrías de
pulso a los entrantes me llaman yo mi
sed lex o sea en uno de los pocos pasos
fronterizos entre ambos países ubicado
entre más chat ciudad de irán y era la
ciudad occidental de afganistán y es que
según el alto comisionado de las
naciones unidas para los refugiados para
finales del año cerca de medio millón de
afganos podría huir de su país
y de audrey o la situación generada es
turbulenta a la gente le preocupa que
pueda estallar de nuevo una guerra civil
estéreo bernstein que los talibanes
todavía no controlan una de las
provincias de afganistán bajo tarea
vivos y la mayoría de los políticos y
han ido de afganistán te equivocas y vos
y ortigosa
los migrantes viajan a través de iran
para llegar hasta turquía con miras a
seguir su camino hacia europa las
autoridades turcas han reforzado su
propia frontera con irak y han expresado
preocupación de que se repita una crisis
de refugiados como la vivida en 2015
como turquía hemos cumplido
suficientemente con nuestras
responsabilidades morales y humanitarias
en materia de inmigración
turquía no puede asumir una nueva carga
de refugiados
turquía que alberga actualmente a 3.7
millones de refugiados sirios advierte
que los países de la región así como
naciones europeas podrían verse
afectadas por los nuevos flujos
migratorios desde afganistán
grecia también ha ampliado su valla
fronteriza con turquía